[Music]
the key to longevity in hollywood is to
not get injured so actors are better off
dodging their punches or just letting
their stunt person step in but what fun
is that we're checking out all the times
marvel actors did not do that and were
accidentally slugged by their co-stars
this is just how it goes over here in
the marvel world
number one
unlike toby maguire being fired for
faking back pain cumberbatch
literally got the boot after a bajillion
unsuccessful attempts at a stunt where
scott atkins was supposed to launch onto
a banister and kick benedict cumberbatch
in the chest safely he had either missed
benedict completely or not hit him hard
enough so on the 10th attempt he decided
it was time to go full out all or
nothing but did he tell benedict that no
of course not for the same shot benedict
thought he'd be a gem and help out his
buddy scott and move just a little bit
closer you can see where this is going
right lights camera injury atkins booted
benedict hard in the chest and
cumberbatch injured his cumber back when
he was smashed backwards against the
banister so weirdly the simplest thing
was the hardest because i had no time to
train to get back into shape number two
it's a pipe dream for hayley atwell to
go a single day without injuring a soul
on set haley whacked a stuntman on the
back with a lead pipe while filming
agent carter she actually injured like
nine or ten stunt people during her time
filming the show this actor might just
win for the most amount of inflicted
injuries or perhaps she's just the most
honest about it she has a fight in her
but i think it means it puts her on the
edge of survival all the time number
three when you don't duck that makes you
the goose shang chi in the legend of the
ten rings was of course heavy into
martial arts and so there was a ton of
close combat fighting star simulio
suffered at least a couple of injuries
one of the worst was when he was whacked
in the face in this epic clip that he
shamelessly shared for the whole world
to see but i was like
i mean it was a very very authentic
moment
number four
capes get you sucked into jet engines
but masks get you socked in the face the
stunt person didn't make the sound that
was supposed to cue tom holland's
response and due to his complete lack of
sight lines thanks to the mask he also
couldn't see the punch so he found
himself completely blindsided by it
[Music]
right hand right across the
masks aren't just a pain when it comes
to avoiding stunts during a night shoot
and the first take of a stunt chadwick
boseman couldn't really see while he was
wearing his mask and so he kneed andy
circus right in the chest circus had the
wind knocked out of him i felt like he'd
broken my ribs he also couldn't stand
back up but despite the pain he
eventually did get back up and go on to
filming the scene 30 more times luckily
not taking another knee to the ribs that
night number six now watch me whip now
watch me injure myself there's a lot of
you know scrapes and bumps and things
chris hemsworth was jealous of loki's
whip and wanted to give it a try for
himself the first time he used it after
accidentally stepping on it he wound up
hitting himself in the face and was left
with a giant welt we bet the makeup team
was not too happy about that i had some
ice on it for a while and the swelling
went down and a bit of makeup fix that
number 7. that feel when you enjoy
inflicting pain on your co-stars manger
zhong was nervous about her fight scene
with simulu simul encouraged me he said
it's okay it's okay she punched him
right in the face the best part was yes
audience can see it in the film what
makes it all so great is that it's also
her favorite scene it was an accident
but it felt good
number eight
there's one move where loki was supposed
to try and spear thor but thor grabs the
spear and elbows loki all good in theory
all good on the long shots but
problematically in a close-up tom had to
snuggle up a little closer to be in the
frame and mid-sequence both the actors
realized at the same time they were just
a wee bit too close and tom was struck
with a spear just kidding he was elbowed
in the face and i remember seeing stars
um because his arms are the size of my
head in another instance hiddleston just
couldn't sell a face smack while wearing
the 30 pound loki horns and when you're
on a time crunch sacrifices have to be
made so he just encouraged the man with
220 pounds of pure muscle the body of a
god chris to smack him across the face i
went down like a stone
number nine
grillo who you may remember played
crossbones in the thread of captain
america movies injured pretty much
everybody on every marvel set he found
himself on he packs one incredibly tough
punch
scarlett johansson recalls walking away
with many many injuries from stunts gone
wrong saying he beat the crap out of me
as you sustain more injuries over time
it hurts for longer and things like that
she'd admitted i guess i like to do as
much of the stunt work as possible and
you take a little bit of risk with that
i'd rather do some of it you know and
have some battle wounds that way i could
compare bruises number 10 do we need to
do this scene again i feel like i got
pretty familiar with chris's kneecap
like once or twice
they whined and dined a few times they
were hitting it off quite literally but
the second things got complicated
sebastian decided it wasn't worth the
pain it was an amicable breakup we're
sure in all seriousness the stunts were
all prepared months in advance so said
sebastian and they all had to be done so
quick on set and he really couldn't feel
the pain until he was on his way home in
the car when i couldn't get out of the
seat
number 11.
frank grillo also punched chris evans if
you don't block frank grillo's punch
you're gonna get knocked actually we're
pretty sure he landed a punch on most of
the cast he doesn't know how to pull his
punches by the end of the six days frank
and chris spent filming an elevator
scene chris admitted he was turning
black and blue both actors were packed
in ice and had to go for massages
because the fight scenes were so cramped
and intense and even when you block a
punch that that punch lands somewhere
anthony mackey will back evans up we
were hitting each other for real number
12.
here's an idea how about we at a scene
where the god of thunder is slapped by a
mere mortal it was natalie portman's
idea for her character to slap thor
after he returned to earth and didn't
call her in thor the dark world needed
to make sure you were real it's been a
very strange day and well she
accidentally slapped chris hemsworth for
real we got some good swings and i think
couple times i made contact by accident
once is an accident twice as a
coincidence at least she didn't get to
three times because that's a pattern
given that it was her idea we can't rule
out that she set the whole thing up on
purpose i was waiting and then i was
crying and then i went out looking for
you who would have thought the cast of
thor would win for the most amount of
unique injuries certainly not us this
was we literally left it all on the
field on this one if you had to film a
stunt scene like these would you let
your stunt person step in for you or
would you let your co-star slap you for
real we imagine that sweet sweet
paycheck might make a difference in the
decision let us know your thoughts in
the comments and thanks for hanging out
with us here at the things